joining us now with her memorial day
message iowa senator and combat veteran
joni ernst senator great to have you
with us this morning on fox and friends
what is your message on memorial day
yes it is exactly what mr carr said is
that we should remember the fallen today
we have so many families that enjoy the
day off from work from school from other
activities but we have to remember the
essence of the day and that is to
remember those that gave selfless
sacrifice the ultimate sacrifice for the
freedoms that we enjoy every single day
so please take time out to remember
those that have fallen for all of us
jack carr not just a writer on
foxnews.com by the way he's a
bestselling author of the terminal list
soon to be at a movie theater near you
senator i also want to talk to you about
your bill that you have put forward it
would use
unused border wall material the stuff
we've seen sitting and rotting now for
over a year that was not deployed the
byte administration
actively took this border wall material
out of service and you're proposing a
bill that would put it back into service
and allow states to finish what the
trump administration started tell us
about this bill what you think you can
accomplish and whether it could pass
yes thanks will and our taxpayers
probably don't realize that president
biden actually called the border wall a
waste of money and yet every single day
the biden administration is paying
contractors upward of three million
dollars to basically babysit the
materials that are left lying in the
desert so my build it act would allow
states to apply to
transfer those materials from the
federal government to those states if
they continue building the wall along
the border there are a number of states
that have already initiated their own
buildings states like arizona and texas
again it's sitting there unused let's
please allow the states to finish the
job
i do have a number of republican
co-sponsors and i actually have a couple
of democrats as well and you can guess
maybe who those democrats are but um
they are the ones that are actually
considering the bill as well so i'd love
to see it pass it really is a waste of
money these are are things that have
already been purchased by the trump
administration sitting there totally
unused by the biden administration i
would love to hear the rebuttal to your
bill articulated explain to me why it's
better not just to let this material rot
but to pay to babysit it while it rots
instead of allowing somebody to use it
we'll see if that makes it to the floor
we can hear that debate all right
senator joni ernst happy memorial day to
you and thank you for being with us
god bless our fallen thank you so much